foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
hello
hello
good morning
hello
keeps wanting to do the trailer what's
up guys how we doing today
yes unfortunately bloodborne is a
PlayStation exclusive
just got bloodborne let's go dude
good morning fear how you guys doing
from software hates money
I don't know about that
I don't know about that
watching you play made me want to play
it that's a good thing right I think so
that's got to be a good thing
anyway
let me hit that real quick
I want to get right into it today
I can play for like
four hours
now I don't think we can beat the whole
game today because I want to do DLC uh
what
we'll see how much we can do today and
if not we'll finish it tomorrow for sure
so let's keep going
this is not my first playthrough I
played I used to speedrun this game a
long time ago it's like four or five
years ago now
but I haven't played since so it's been
a long time
but I have like I'd say
700 hours in this game there's a lot of
stuff I don't remember especially about
the story like when you're a speedrunner
you don't you go down one route
and you don't really like look at
anything you just kind of do the route
and beat the bosses you know
so this is more of a a playthrough
yes I saw that Cameron I I listen to it
it's sick
I joined the hunt I did
how sick I look uh so I think we beat uh
the worst boss in bloodborne what's his
name again
the one that laughs all the time
mikalash I think is how you say it
we beat him thank God worst boss in the
game
yeah Mikko [ __ ]
yes Stan Hi man we beat we beat gun deer
dude one I am actually gonna play Dark
Souls 3 soon like I think
we might do one more cool Elden ring
stream in between Dark Souls three
no I can't the lore in this game has
already been done to death I I don't
need to add any more onto it
so I don't think I'll make more videos
in bloodborne
promotion I love that
forehead
look at these weird dogs
favorite from software boss radon
rodon has definitely take taken that
that spot for me
these are literally the Shadows what up
dudes
oh my God
do a lot of damage sir
yeah I love this weapon the cleaver
you can change it from short to long and
then like one of the best parts of this
game
is you can like interchangeably use
attack so if I go RV lb lb
it's a nice combo
love it
the lore is just having a fever dream
you're not wrong it's a little deeper
than that
there's the third one
being a forehead
ow
let's go
sir
ear death
I mean there are interchangeable weapons
in Elden ring isn't there
let me do something real quick
I gotta make the chat bigger my eyes are
a little puffy today I can't see hello
hello
there we go
there we go
excellent
okay
who do we have next I forget
um
oh yeah
the baby well we don't fight the baby
obviously but
foreign
something that takes care of the baby I
think or something like that
I don't remember the okay
they have eyes all over them
hmm
yes the wet nurse that's what it is
I don't know if I want to fight two of
these guys
yep that'd be why
I think I'm out of here [ __ ] this
nope
three
three
okay bro
or checkpoint up here maybe
oh hello
no this isn't New Game Plus what died
over there I just got 9 000 I got 9 000
Echoes for doing nothing
oh
why are you crying
that looks painful
now I can't stop thinking of morga in a
nurse outfit
is that really that bad
yes bloodborne is blowing me
I don't know if the if the nurse is
horny or not
the pigs fight the Shadows perfect that
worked out
can I talk to you no okay I'm sorry that
you're crying
yeah I know some of the lore I don't
remember all of it though
[Music]
blood vile
cool
I don't know if she's horny man
might be the opposite of that actually
in the Lord
okay where am I here
where is this
oh okay
perfect little
little
shortcut
you think I should do the DLC before the
wet nurse or can I do the wet nurse and
then the DLC
or is the DLC not even accessible
the hardest from software boss ooh
that's a tough question
it might be orphan of costs
um if not that then Melania just for her
[ __ ]
I think
it's definitely not gun deer gun deer is
a
new wet nurse first I'm just wondering
if like am I locked off from the DLC if
I do something
yeah I'll also eachine I I always forget
about eachine
might be harder than Melania actually
Madeira is not hard once you know what
you're doing
I'll be fine I'm gonna say that beating
DLC bosses before wetness is probably
better
because you get special dialogue when
you're killing some DLC bosses that you
don't get if you kill the wet nurse okay
well I want the dialogue
let's go do the DLC
that sounds exciting
let's do it
yeah I would say the rest of Melania is
actually like easy compared to
the only thing that makes Melania hard
is the waterfall dance that is literally
it
everything else you can get used to and
it's not that bad
I think Gail is a hard boss
but he's not like the hardest boss for
me
the doll is basically locked into saying
one thing after wet nurse and won't say
the DLC boss's lines gotcha gotcha okay
let's go do that
I have to go get abducted right
what up mug how are you
didn't get the notification today dude I
got the notification
okay I think I got some big boys too
you're
dude
just a casual 20K don't worry about it
then oh man we are killing it actually
I can level up twice
I'm gonna do skill a bit my skill is so
low
no I don't think plastic do sex is
really all that hard
I think he's awesome oh well good Hunter
may you find your worth in the waking
world
what up Jake
that's my name
let's see what we can upgrade
garmin's been gone for a while dude I
don't know how I feel about that
you have any better one of these we do
uh throw that on
could be
a full HP that's a little better
that's just bolt damage I'm not too
crazy about that
you're watching me at school pay
attention
you better pay attention
um I can go somewhere and find a bunch
of uh
Stones potentially actually potentially
for sure
um
[Music]
be sure I missed a bunch of them here
actually
let me go check it out real quick
sometimes gearman sits watching the moon
left of the second Workshop entrance
I I don't know I think he's been gone
gone like he's already in the garden
I'm not sure when he goes over there
though
oh this is not exactly where I want it
to be
French toast sticks dude
um we'll see how far we get today Ito
we'll see how far we get
I don't want to be down there but I kind
of messed that up didn't I
oh he's chilling okay maybe I just
missed him I don't know
I'm watching you through a hurricane
yeah if you guys are in Florida
be careful out there man that doesn't
look good
that doesn't look good at all
no I'm not trying to go to the DLC yet
trying to find more bloodstones
I think they're out here I am not
fighting these guys
yeah Tampa didn't look good man so good
luck
I hope all is all will be okay
you're in the UK watching me play
bloodborne [ __ ] yeah dude
see we got some chunky boys over here I
think I'm dead though
cause they're following me
pop out
oh this is terrifying do I get chunks
from uh biting these guys
I'm so dead
pal I'm alive
don't ask
we simply are
pretty far in so it's not too bad
that's great Stefan
it's like I already answered that though
damn it
I really be ducking and dodging right
now sir
it did like all my health
is the UK really that bad
there's no way this compares to the UK
come on
oh that's twin [ __ ]
take those blood vials though for sure
hello
who's shooting me oh I didn't even see
brother
it's pretty close all right man
you say so what the heck is in here
oh God please now
okay
foreign
UK after the queen released the Scarlet
rot
that's a good blood jump
it's a five banger
it seems like the world kind of
unraveled after the queen died did
anyone else notice that
was the queen holding everything
together we
okay I've already been here
is there an a place where I can buy
like can I use insight to buy
um Stone chunks
well I should go down here actually
I don't get sniped
yeah I think I can
I'm sure I'm missing some on the ground
here but that's okay
thank you
stop shooting me please stop it right
now
she stopped the Stars so basically
you're saying Queen Elizabeth was redone
right
Star Search Queen
star Scourge Elizabeth
I won't play bloodborne again until it
comes PC I'm done with 30 FPS gaming
yeah it's frustrating
it's definitely frustrating my guy
my eyes get used to it pretty quickly
though because I have a like a lot of
experience
with older games
let me check these real quick as well
since I'm distracted
I think we got everything we want yeah
we're good there
um insight
this is the Insight one
yeah I can they're 20 each but it gives
me five okay cool they gave me that that
seems worth
and you guys were telling me to
definitely buy my insight right
dude I need two more
[Music]
well maybe we'll get them in the DLC
did you finish any Quest I don't know
I don't know what starts and ends Quest
so to be honest with you welcome what is
it here
I don't think I can level off this or no
I found I found a poppy boy
sorry farewell Good Hunter
I access my thing please thank you
there we go
that's not enough though
let's go to the ward
[Music]
what's gonna be a deep conversation for
today's stream do we have deep
conversations on here
your voice is epic I don't believe you
will you make lorevids on bloodborne
more than likely no
kanehurst and upper Cathedral Ward yet
I feel like I have have I
I'm not sure
we still got our chick in the corner we
do hello
what's wrong
[Laughter]
what what's what's so [ __ ] funny mate
foreign
I'm getting weirded out by how much
you're laughing
okay uh what what what's happening man
holy [ __ ]
whoa
okay
I wanna kill her that's terrifying holy
[ __ ]
yeah I had allergies the other day I
feel I feel fine today though thank you
for asking
yeah what happened to her what did you
do to her bro
alive and well are you
a safe place stay as long as you like I
already know that but next time you're
out on a hunt remember what I asked
if you find any sane survivors tell them
a seek shell or an urban Chapel I mean I
did nothing to fear here
why why are we just laughing this off
man like I don't know about that why are
we just laughing this off this feels a
little weird
I don't know how I feel about this
Jesus okay should I get abducted
oh I can just plainly see you now
excellent
welcome
we're all gonna die
all right let's get abducted I think I
stand here
grab me Daddy grab me
yes
that's not the right one again is it
I Kill The Creeper Church dude right
away dude he is the nicest guy in the
game
it's just a little odd
wait am I not in the DLC
you need the item from Hunter's dream oh
okay
the eye of blood drunk Hunter
no I didn't kill any creeper
where is that
[Music]
these are all the Chalice dungeon things
right
it should be on the stairs
have I eaten any umbilical cords
uh
after vicar Amelia I definitely killed
her like days ago
long time
are you sure you have DLC downloaded
yeah I swear
I mean I should
oh
start a new game plus and kill her
I don't think that's how that works
Punk
why would I not have the DLC
hold on let me check
starting soon screen
you all don't get my information and try
to kill me
all right let me see how do I check this
so
uh
downloads and uploads
[Music]
I don't know how to work my PS5 to be
totally honest with you okay
bloodborne view product
I mean does it not come with the DLC
like do I have to [ __ ] buy it oh I do
[ __ ] it's ten dollar eight guys it's 50
off right now if you're curious why does
this not come with it what the hell I
still gotta pay
all right
infirm we're downloading it now
whoopsie
it's 50 off guys if you're curious
hopefully this doesn't ruin my stream
that I try to download this
uh
uh okay I purchased I purchased it do I
need to download it
view game
play game
oh
can we do a lore stream
[Music]
I don't have to download it it's just
there
you guys like the wipe away effect I
kind of like it oh
[Music]
I do need to download it okay well I'll
restart the game
everybody hold
everybody hold
everybody calm
down
okay
close game
closing this gamer app
uh uh
view product
yo I could have subscribed with my
premium oh piss
complete edition bundle
is that not what I [ __ ] got dog
what does complete edition mean that's
the one I got
[Music]
I'm confused I don't know how to
download it guys I did do the thing
guys you can buy uh messenger top hats
by the way if you're interested in that
I don't have premium
the stream is down everybody panic
[Laughter]
uh okay it says I purchased it view game
play game
[Music]
I mean will it just like do it
foreign
restarting
it's all okay guys
right
it's getting to me
it's getting to me guys
hold on I'm not gonna switch back until
I know it's there
there it is
yay
just sitting there didn't have to
download it it's you just buy it and
it's there
it's thick
the eye of the drunk Hunter beckons
Hunters to the Hunter's nightmare
yay
what do you have to say about that well
what is it here
Good Hunter
your presence somehow soothes
she likes me since the ancient echoes
they curse your veins
farewell Good Hunter
may you find your worth in the waking
world
guys do you like doll what what is her
name doll welcome what is it will it
tell me no farewell Good Hunter do you
guys like her or Ronnie more
question
okay so now I go get abducted
well lady Maria isn't a doll
right
gundir is the answer
her name is actually Maria how do you
how do you figure that
Ronnie is up her ass
what was the DLC for bloodborne was it
Story related oh yeah we about to go
there right now
let's go check it out guys
is Ludwig a part of the DLC
I don't remember I think so right
because that might be the best boss in
all these games
I will be turning the music all the way
up I want you to know that
the music will be
and their children forever true
I like this song
that wasn't creepy
this is fine
you know what I just thought of guys
and this is gonna blow your mind
I don't think I've ever done the DLC
now that I think about it
I've seen it I've watched it but I don't
think I've played it
because I speed ran any percent
I think I played the game once before
DLC was released
and then I speed ran any percent
I don't think I've ever done these
bosses
I've seen it though I know what they
look like I know the soundtracks
okay
are you saying I'm under leveled what
level am I
I'm level 60.
is that all right
yeah well I already got kidnapped for
sure
no I mean I know what's going on but I
don't know everything so don't don't
spoil a ton
but uh
is this the cathedral award
yeah it is there's nobody's here
80 minimum oh [ __ ]
oh
whoa what the [ __ ]
this reminds me of what the
yeah I don't I've never played this
I don't remember this at all
it's like ring City
hey I don't need those
what happened here this is like Ashton
Capital City kinda
are they gonna fight that's a hunter
kill
holy titties
whoa
yo what up dog
no we don't gotta fight we don't have to
we don't have to I'm chilling
what you thinking
Blunderbuss of course
guys this guy's gonna beat my booty
guys
okay I'm just better
I'm just way better than that guy
Pro Gamer
way better than that guy
his weapon was cool
hey
did I not just [ __ ] murder your ass
okay might be somebody else
whoa
this really reminds me of ring City from
Dark Souls 3.
it's giving me a lot of blood vials what
is the game telling me right now man
yeah I don't remember any of this I man
I don't think I have played the DLC I
don't think I have for real
I'm a sham
well I don't know about this guys
okay we got another Hunter
yes kill them for me
excellent
what has he got look at that hammer bro
what so why is he fighting me
[Applause]
please turn into a beast
scarecrow
I'm gonna leave him alone well there's a
lot of hunters here
oh
okay I know I killed you
how did my bullet Miss so bad
sir
all the hunters have gone mad except for
me
except for me
I'm fine
foreign
blood drunk
Hunters fight not just you that is good
news I suppose
I'm fine this is fine
you can get their outfit I mean look at
my FIT bro I'm pretty sick looking
I love how this game just constantly
coats you in blood
oh it's a trap
hello
just slowly back away
sir
you're fat and ugly you're actually not
fat at all I'm sorry
giving me a lot of blood vials
sorry I'm slowly going through this area
yeah we got another Baddie over there
this looks
sometimes I gotta look
this one is a shortcut
or that left probably that left or over
here because that's left and that was
right and I'm dumb
y'all stay right there and [ __ ] off
the left to your right right exactly
right right right left right right left
right
hmm
everybody calm down it's just a nobody
has been
I'm way better
oh he didn't die oh you are
old Hunter cap
I want to see what it looks like
[Music]
okay this looks cool I like this
I'm gonna rock this hat
um so this is the shortcut up here now
yeah I came out of there and I can just
come up this way okay cool
I kind of do look a little gangster
right now
and I don't really gotta worry about
armor
get up here
glitch
whoops
bold
never mind
stay over there
are you [ __ ] with you you don't gotta
[ __ ] with me I think that's a fair
game
okay
I mean oh oh oh oh
is it coming this way yep sure is
hey I like that that was good
let's keep doing that let's keep killing
things for me
okay
[Music]
the doors are opening for me
oh it's opening for
oh
hey dog go back in there I'm gonna be
down here
evil West I have not heard of that game
yo dude chill holy [ __ ]
[Music]
let me in there [ __ ]
guys I'm gonna die
run Everybody Run
I don't know about that I did not like
any of that
I gotta fight vicar again
is that cleric Beast
oh
okay where am I
am I in another world
I pendant
lore
is it a key yep
lore an eye pendant which unlocks the
surgery altar there are two cathedrals
in a hunter's dream
one lies past the rivers rivers of blood
and another contains the private
research Hall of the healing Church
only chosen members of the healing
church or their
dyslexic word I can't say patience can
enter the research Hall using this eye
grants eyes to the surgery altar skull
okay
I gotta fight this guy
uh he's easy he's gonna be a nerd
oh
so what did I find a key that's going to
open another door
to the uh inside the church
I don't think I want to fight this guy
I'm not about it I'm gonna run past him
can I go this way
still nope
I may have just [ __ ] myself
no I I've seen Lawrence I know like I've
seen the boss fight I've heard the music
I just I've never personally fought him
myself I don't think
doggies
they're mad showing
get our hunter
my Ferry timing is kind of sick huh
it's kind of goated
hmm
more blood Wheels
open
I'm just kind of nuts with it
more blood veils
yeah I think I'm lost
just a little bit
there
oh I see
I go up there
I'll hang a left
I think I can drop down yeah yeah
Beast cutter
that looks pretty cool
definitely gonna stick with this weapon
though
are these beasts like hiding
who's behind me right now hello
where'd you come from man kill these
[ __ ]
okay you're aggressive
I miss my Perry
I talk too much [ __ ]
literal morgot delay
noticing he's getting Health back when
he hits me
there it is
foreign
I gotta trust my parries
I'm not bad at it at all
let's go back up here
I'm level 60 right now
the next area is to the right of the
last staircase okay
it doesn't look like I can go over there
so
ah
thank you
[Music]
okay sorry I got a little Chub
oh
oh damn that looks good
what is this I'm dealing with though
yes Von winkleshark does not have to
deal with a level
Von winkleshart has no need for level
only I could Crouch
it's happening
go go go
so they can turn and shoot
was that another one
yeah that one dead ass turned around
hey guys
foreign
oh you're a hunter you are a hunter got
it
why are they chill with him and not me
oh I'm in trouble
bye bye
nope nope nope
I know what it's like to get ganked
I play Dark Souls 2 for six hours
I know exactly what it's like to get
ganked
foreign
am I close to a lantern
of any kind
I've been had
we'll trap though
this door always open
hey I don't know about you
but I'm feeling 22.
dog you good
I nope
guys everything I'm coming across is
just a nope
I feel like I'm under level
where are you
I'm doing no damage
foreign
I got five bullets
yeah I I I I don't know about this
I'm doing no damage to him
startled
nope
I just don't like any of that oh God
where am I now
is this a [ __ ] swap mate
minor [ __ ] swamp
thank you
the blood vials were needed
it finally happened
oh man
guys Joy's asleep on my bed right now
and she looks [ __ ] adorable
other side of the river all right
man
take us back a few steps mate Jesus
Christ
like I didn't do anything for half an
hour
okay
[Music]
no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no
oh God
Pro Gamer
went right through that [ __ ]
oh no
oh
rip 30k echoes
30k Rippy dippy
I don't think I was ever gonna get back
to that though
no cap
guys I feel like I'm a bit under levels
for here dude
Blunderbuss this butthole dude
I'm gonna keep going though
keep going
epic gamer
I didn't uh didn't get past that one
there
didn't uh
didn't time that one right
dude Brian is just man you are the
biggest backseat gamer I've ever had in
a chat room dude I'm not gonna lie to
you man I appreciate some help but don't
tell me everything dude I'm sorry
yep I ducked and I should have dipped
when I needed to dodge
but I will stick to the left okay I see
thank you
you don't get bloodborne on the Xbox
that's the answer you don't get it
it don't exist on the Xbox
okay that one right there is a little
sketch
how did I get past this
like that
May the board guide your way
[Applause]
I found a top hat okay you guys want me
to go this way
we got one I don't know about these guys
I got stuck and I'm dead it's over I
died
please so let me let me get these off
please
okie dokie
we somehow made it through that
give me chunkies
yeah yeah
[Music]
I don't like it
Chuck
run
oh God
guys
I don't like it here
I'm [ __ ] [ __ ] that
why did you tell me to come here
please stop shooting me
how many bullets do you have but
this is where I [ __ ] came from bruh
guys where where is the shortcut
you guys said I was close I don't know
if I was close
okay [ __ ]
all right
please be [ __ ] friendly
please
yo you're a hunter with your sanity huh
holy crap must have taken a wrong turn
then a
well we're more alike than you think
this is the Hunter's nightmare
where Hunters end up when drunk with
blood
you've seen them before
aimless wandering Hunters so everybody's
drunk
this is what the poor fools have to look
forward to so
don't be brash
turn back before it's too late
unless you something of an interest in
nightmares
um
I mean if I were to answer this like
myself I'd be like get me the [ __ ] out
of here right now but
nightmares are interesting oh yes I see
you sense a secret within the Nightmare
and cannot bear to leave it be
as if the spirit of bergenworth lives on
within you such inquisitive hunters will
relish the nightmare
but beware trying to look at them it's
the secrets for a reason and some do not
wish to see them uncovered
especially when the secrets are
particularly unseemly
okay beware
secrets are secrets for a reason secrets
are secrets
secret secrets are no fun secret Seekers
can hurt someone
yeah he said that
a door
please open thank you please be the
cathedral
oh yes
get me out of here
I'll come back but
man the dlc's hard huh man
DLC is hard bro
ah yes
now we need a blood Rock we only need
one Blood rock to upgrade
Uno Blood rock
so where
where is this place
[Music]
[Music]
it's Pearl
isn't that here
that's that's that [ __ ]
this one
[Music]
oh it's a grave upstairs
really like over here
where the doll goes
oh wow okay gotcha thank you
is that why she was looking at it was it
for the DLC or was it just for another
reason
I think I like this doll more than
Ronnie
Ronnie kinda uses us anyone else noticed
that
Ronnie's kind of a [ __ ]
a little bit
hey man it's true
the grave is probably lady Maria's
all right
okay that looks like something that we
need to go to
okay he's big chilling right there
let's go this way
yo
why are you running away
nope don't like that at all
it's a big old nope to me
why they got iframes
okay
this area is terrifying
close to Ludwig oh God
I'm scared
is Ludwig hard
I'm gonna do the thing
I might do the thing wait
music's all the way up guys
all the way up
yeah dude [ __ ] Ronnie
Bulldog first
yes he's hard
I was hoping you'd say he's easy
foreign
for me he's easy
of course
obviously
what is this
foreign
holy titties dude
well like from soft put this game on PC
now
remaster it because this looks good
but it could look so much better
on PC man like this is nuts
put it on [ __ ] PC please so I can max
out my my [ __ ]
it looks so good
what is that
okay
just a dude with a cannon
oh hey
okay
I'm not okay with any of that any of
that any of that hello
why okay
come help me bro
#free bloodborne
you think PS showcase will show
remastered no I don't
I think
from software
is very happy with their Elven ring
release
and they are relaxing
you know how hard it was probably to
make Eldon ring in its entirety they're
probably taking a break
turn right
okay
hey
calm down
dude these things are moving
get another boy
another helper
okay
look at this guy
why are they like skinned
making a break yeah I think from
software is taking a much deserved break
and we won't see DLC until
I'm not going to cap with you guys a
year from now
for Elden ring
yeah I'll go this way
ah yes
lamp acquired
do I go down here
or back where I was
I think the DLC is already done I don't
think so at all
no way
gives you five blood vials every time
okay I'll give them a little Bonk
I just feel bad for him you know
all right let's go this way
I don't know what my boys are doing but
I don't really care
oh
please
help us
a great Terror
have mercy
I have mercy Apollos he looks like a
horse to me
oh God
[Music]
music's turned all the way up guys
it's that guy laughing man
oh my God
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Victor thank you man
I appreciate that
[Music]
[Applause]
this music couldn't be better
[Music]
[Applause]
holy [ __ ]
foreign
[Music]
on a white guy
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
Pro Gamer
zero deaths did you guys [ __ ] hear
that thatch though
does it get better than that
wait I gotta pull it up because that
ended way too quick we just killed him
way too fast
does it get better than that Music Man
Ludwig
like where it starts the the second
phase of it man
listen to this [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I gotta listen to it again sorry
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
but like my God is that not just that
that OST just blows my mind dude it
really does it's so good
all right what do you got what do you
got to say man good Hunter
have you seen the thread of light
just a hair a fleeting thing
yet I clung to it steeped as I was in
the
oath of blood
Beast
I never wanted to know what it really
was really I didn't
you say he was a hunter
[Music]
okay I mean does this game
this is a [ __ ] Horror Show
yeah he's blood drunk
he was one of the best hunters
horsey go nay
um should I [ __ ] kill him can I smack
his head
extremely lame you summoned that many
NPCs for the best boss in the game I
didn't know if they were gonna follow me
into the boss fight dude calm down
imagine carrying you [ __ ] dork
put him out of his misery
okay
good night sweet prince
[Music]
holy Moonlight sword
um we might change what we got going on
here what do I need I need 14 arcane
and I put it on
I can't even equip it just to look
why do I still hear him
hello
oh I think I'm hearing that guy
go back
yeah it's it's literally Ronnie's sword
just like a different color
it's the best weapon in the game I mean
should I upgrade my Arcane to get it
hello
[Music]
yeah that OST is just it blows my mind
dude
what do you guys think
Ronnie stole Ludwig's sword
they look very similar
you don't have enough shards to upgrade
I mean I probably do
um because I've only upgraded one sword
yeah look at all these I have 22 shards
24 twin I got a chunk we could level it
pretty decently for sure
[Music]
yeah Moonlight sword was in Dark Souls 2
as well I don't remember it in Dark
Souls 1.
level up Arcane just fun to check it out
what is it okay
very well I don't think I can level very
much though
not to 14.
no I Can Only Live Twice is it even
worth it
maybe we do that in like a new game
I feel like I should level up skill
if anything
yeah I'm gonna stick with this weapon
we don't gotta change [ __ ] up just
because it looks cool
I'm cool with it
okay okay
I'm assuming there was more to go to
obviously
[Music]
sorry to get mad at whoever that was
that told me it was lame to uh
use summons one I didn't know they'd be
there like I thought they were just for
the outside area like they were so far
before the boss and two I hate it when
people try to gatekeep somebody else's
playthrough like you can go play go and
play through the game yourself without
using summons it's just so lame to me
when people do that hello hey it's that
guy a tragic figure
but he will shame himself no longer
he died I did not mean to do that I
moved my leg and I accidentally owned oh
God I'll be back I'm sorry
can we restart
I tried to okay
he
died with his ideals undarnished
he was a true hero thank god dude
I moved my leg man
he was like you sure you want to do that
do you because it's sprouted from that
very Misty
it's things that some would rather keep
secret I'm thinking about it ioto
arrogance really
High time someone exposed the whole
charade
I did try and do that once and it it did
not do well comparatively to other
videos but maybe I just shouldn't
[ __ ] care no no
go on ahead
you seek nightmares and the secrets
within do not yeah gearman's theme
is really good that second phase though
is just like
so nice
good night sweet prince
so was he like
eating the skin of all of these people
for their blood
or skinning them for the blood
maybe make a second Channel I
here's what's gonna happen if I make a
second Channel
all my time is gonna be
because I'm the one who does everything
for the channel I do all the editing
all the research
everything
streaming
now I'm making shorts
we got one coming out in 40 minutes
but it it my time would be spread out
way too thin
I just wouldn't be able to like
I would like how do I put it
I don't want to do that I don't wanna
spread out my time and I just I don't
think it's necessary to have a second
Channel
maybe if who knows
I don't think the second channel is a
good idea
and when I asked the community
they wanted one channel
foreign
it's the dung eater
hello
he's banging his head on the wall
colored by Blood but always clear with
mind
crowd under the church
be circles and it causes a shackle
only the true blade to the church okay
he's saying a bunch of
whoa
don't compare another dung eater all I'm
saying is he's banging his head against
the wall
which is what dung eater does
that's it that's all I'm saying
yes these these guys are tanking hits I
just died
two hits
I think I got shot
um can I see what the doll says should I
try that
and maybe we should go do
the the normal game stuff
or do you think I can get through the
whole DLC like this
combo
hi Brandon
he's reciting the Hunter's pledge
the guy in the back shot you
no I have not defeated Koss
I'm assuming yeah
keep going we'll keep going
man
foreign
game you still have Ellen's Quest upper
Cathedral Ward Kane Hearst and Albert's
Quest okay
what do you think I should do first
you go Jim yep I was at the well I have
like a tiny home gym it's not a home gym
I have
like a rack and free weights and things
like that
so I work out at home
if I worked out this morning I always I
always work out when I wake up
and then maybe one other time during the
day
but feel like it that's mostly like
cardio hello
wow
that's very odd
do you hear the tone of the Bell
I do hear a bell
often
liar okay
such pettiness will be your undoing it's
a redditor the Beast you seek will not
be found here
go back to your heart
and if you had the chance to put this
Knight behind you
places
um I'm getting there
hold on
cause I I mean how much weight Have I
Lost in the last two years I started
work because I got fat
I mean I wasn't fat I was just really
big like
I worked out a lot but I also ate like
[ __ ] and I'm five foot nine and I was
like 230 pounds I'd say
and now I'm
I'm sitting like right at 185 to 190 so
I've lost a bunch of weight
because I tried to get big like I wanted
to be bigger like just bulkier and when
I got there I didn't like being that
heavy so now I'm trying to get back down
to if I could be back at 170 like I was
in college then I think that would be
perfect for me that's when I felt the
best
so
a lot of weight loss I have like 15 more
to go
but I'll get there eventually
whoa
non-metric units sorry I'm a [ __ ]
dumbass American
great one's wisdom is that like a bunch
of insight
hey you can do it Daniel
just gotta be consistent
okay
fine
I'm fine with this
sword is cool
why does everything want to hurt me
hey you're hard to carry sir
okay
okay
my metabolism is fluid I fluctuate and
wait my entire life yeah I mean
so when I was in college I was pretty
tiny like I was like one five nine like
160. pretty skinny and I didn't like
feeling that skinny
so
I got I just bulked up like I ate a [ __ ]
ton of food whether it was like good or
bad for me just to gain weight got up
buddy
um
and I got all the way up to 230 which is
way more weight than I should weigh
um
and I got up there and I like I said I
just didn't like the feeling you know
what I'm saying
I don't like feeling that heavy even
though like I did what I wanted
now I'm on my way back down and I feel
better than ever
let's try it again
thank you
appreciate that sir
go
okay I guess I don't do any damage to
these guys
thank you white soap the man
hopefully this is an elevator of some
kind yep excellent
sounds good Samantha have a great day
you know thank you again man
there we go
went from 240ish to 190 it's super hard
for me to get to under 190. yeah if
you're 6'3
that seems like a perfect weight
to be honest
this depends on what you're going for
like what kind of I was gonna say what
kind of build you're going for like even
with your own body like I'm talking like
a [ __ ] Elden Ring character but you
know it's like the same thing
essentially
there's a secret under the elevator
oh whoa whoa
mid Max min max the lanky build
I like it man
I like it
oh I need you
okay we got some chunkies
Lawrence's skull
and we already get it
blue Elixir oh
see in my eyes
drop
everything's pale
now
okay
um sorry to hear that my guy
hope you uh hope you find them
because I don't want to go in there
when you hear those Whispers in the boom
you're getting more inside oh you're
right
read signboard
first floor balcony all right I feel
like it says a lot more than that but
okay
that [ __ ] locked anyway
quickly quickly
[ __ ]
oh I gotta pick him up piss I thought
they just get my inventory for some
reason
okay let's go upstairs
there's something over here there's lots
of oars and [ __ ]
does not open from this side
laboratory floor number Uno
uh oh here they come
you gotta activate the elevator and hop
off and you'll see if you want to fight
Lawrence later later
that bot didn't spam
looking to get that bot though
all right so thank you man
this game is your average Wednesday in
London did I need to uh well actually I
was planning on going to London but
maybe not now
hey thank you dude I appreciate you okay
did you mean down there
it
oh
but thank you it'so I appreciate it man
few bucks each thank you
secret is below
okay these guys say so
years back I would do two boiled eggs
for breakfast yep to break your fast eat
trail mix snacks PB and J for dinner for
like two three months
265 222 it was tortured yeah how many
like so you said two boiled eggs
rail makes snacks PB and J that's got to
be like a thousand calories Max
that must [ __ ] suck dude I'm sorry
yeah the hunters will still be there
okay
letting with your stream as always
hope it's going well Esther
forgot you shoot
okay let's activate
pop off
can I just go below oh
okay uh got it I see it
Lawrence's skull
I appreciate you Jake your losses are
dope flexed biceps Lex biceps let's go
bro thank you dude I'm glad you like
them and thank you for watching them
I think we're stuck here forever
foreign
this might be the best place for me to
be
damn it
but thank you Ito
appreciate all the super chats
anyone else get on Twitch get porn Bots
that actually DM you
oh man you guys want to talk about
[ __ ] twitch and YouTube
I think twitch is dying dude
I really do think twitch is going in the
gutter
me alone for just a [ __ ] second
we're going down okay [ __ ] off people
scared
why are those Hunters so strong
Church Cannon
dude I need 16
blood inch
fist
okay
yeah I love this game
twitch streamers earn money by showing
their feet I that's not even like the
issue dude like yeah people show their
feet and they earn money but like people
do that on all kinds of platforms
I'm saying
yeah I'm struggling with these guys more
than the [ __ ] bosses dude
step on and off
oh I gotta hit the thing don't I
okay that's fine
take me back upstairs
that's a cap Sabi that's a cap
that's a cap
twitch dying from too much taxes on the
rich uh I don't know about that either
it's just more like all right what what
do you guys get when you go to Twitch
what do you guys get
do we do you guys even watch Twitch
it's hard to say with with YouTube chat
we'll talk we'll talk about this real
quick and then I gotta take the dogs
outside and I'm gonna go P2 and then
we'll be back
porn I'm not saying porn
maybe you guys don't like pretty much
when I get on Twitch
I get an ad
every time I open a stream whether I'm
watching a new streamer or a streamer I
watch all the time I'm just constantly
getting ads dude
and you know what I do when I get an ad
that I can't skip like you can on
YouTube you can skip ads if you want to
after like five seconds
is
I [ __ ] leave
I leave the twitch stream every time
it it's without fail every single time I
leave that stream I either try and go to
a stream that I'm subscribed to so I
won't get ads
or I leave the website entirely and you
know what I open
I open YouTube
pretty much
without fail every single time
yeah they add you to death and it's not
like one
and second ad it sometimes I'm watching
a twitch stream and I get seven
15 second ads all unskippable it's like
why why would I ever stay and watch also
dog [ __ ] ads
but why would I stay there and then you
guys see that uh for creators they're
they're it's everyone's gonna be at a 50
50 split
whereas on YouTube
it's a 70 30 split why would you not
stream on YouTube you know what I mean
and then like usually the uh the
argument there is there's like more of a
culture on streaming for twitch than
YouTube but to me it's like that might
be the case with you guys like with you
not really being used to live streams on
YouTube but that's why I'm streaming so
that we can create a community together
which will create a culture
to probably being similar if not better
than Twitch in the future so you got to
start somewhere in on you know
especially for creators on Twitch
there's no discoverability at all like
all I had if I wanted to grow my twitch
I had to make tick tocks and YouTube
videos to to even get followers on
Twitch
otherwise they'll never see you unless
you have 20 000 viewers already
if you don't already have viewers on
Twitch there is no reason to stream on
Twitch absolutely none the only way I
had to grow was make YouTube videos and
tick tocks and and that was it with
plugging my twitch and all of them to
hopefully get people to switch platforms
which people don't like to do they like
to be on one platform
you know
I would much rather watch on YouTube I'm
already subscribed to people I like and
I don't want to move platforms for no
reason I agree I absolutely
yeah so we're we're creating a culture
here I think YouTube is the future of
streaming so you know whether or not
twitch is better for streaming
I mean we're gonna grow something here
and it's gonna be fun so
okay I have to go pee the dogs have to
go pee I will be right back guys give me
like five minutes
mine
um
I am gonna play
the
Ludwig song while I'm gone
let me turn down
this hoe real quick
but I'll be right back guys give me five
minutes five minutes max maybe maybe six
minutes
all right enjoy
BRB
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
okay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
that took me three and a half minutes
[Applause]
you don't we're back
you don't even get to hear the good part
you don't even get to hear the good part
now that I'm back all right
thank you
I was that quick with it
the only times I discovered people on
Twitch is because they played an old PS1
game that I liked
and watch people with
buest concurrent viewers
I see you're one of those people which
is fine that's good
okay let's go up here
no I did not
my dog is a girl she does not have a
willy
ah
Joy is a girl
she burned the air tree
why are they so fast
it's creepy
hello
I like to support the small channels
well ow hello
what just exploded in my face okay that
almost killed me
you know okay so what if your small
channel gets big
will you just leave
a lot of people
will say no
but they do
ah it's a tile switch dude that guy just
got
[ __ ] up dude
hello
open please
excellent
I see a switch I touch switch
oh they're traps on the ground my bad my
bad
you got one over here too
can't hit that one
where does this go
ion some stay under 100 followers or I'm
out man
I feel so bad for that Creator though
you know
wait
why I thought you'd stay there [ __ ]
oh
oh [ __ ]
okay
um
is that you lady Maria yep
you're someone else look how'd you know
sorry I was sipping my water I'm sipping
big sippin please
could you do something for me I don't
know bro
I need brain fluid okay monkey
mushy brain fluid
okay
please I
do
it
um
are their heads like wrapped up
I don't know where to get you brain
fluid my guy I really don't
yep everybody be drinking water right
now
if you're not starving I'm not
supporting you
no my streamer can only live off the two
dollar donations I give them
every week they can only afford a
McGriddle once a week if they're not
starving [ __ ] them
that's not how it is I'm kidding
hey nice shot idiot
me
that's what you sound like dumbass
holy peace
Beast dog I don't know how people drink
black coffee I'm sorry that that stuff
is so gross to me
I have pumpkin spice creamer and I have
um think of this I have Cinnamon Toast
Crunch creamer
it tastes delicious
I love cinnamon toast crunches obviously
whoa
yo yo yo chill chill everyone chill
it's a lot healthier to drink black
coffee
oh my God Dawn
decorative old Hunter garb
that actually looked kind of sick
110.
wait is that all I found no
oh [ __ ]
I look like I'm in the Confederacy I
don't like it
go naked Jakey for a while
all right let's get our fit going here
so
old Hunter top hat
okay
under two different Hunter garbs
gas coins Garb butcher garb
these are all trash though
I was wearing this
then I'll wear butcher gloves
incredible trousers oh
yeah I like this
I like this
yeah
you having trouble with the door my guy
I can hit him through the door
physics
that's what that is
pure physics
laboratory floor two
where are these things on the floor
I don't see him dog
feeder's Helm bone Ash legs sounds lit
it's over here did I already open this
no are you nice you are nice a sunflower
hello
is that what any of you thought he'd say
they're so unexpected
I'll leave you to your sunflower flip
flop man I like flip-flop
all right who's crying up here
foreign
experiment gone wrong oh whoa almost
died
okay what what what's going on here
what did you do
okay
is there a device a device of some kind
probably
it's me I'm crying okay I'm sorry
flip flop
flip flop
yeah is the sock lever just like really
good I mean obviously
but
It's gotta be one of the best weapons in
the game right
oh you're not alive okay cool
use the [ __ ] dungeon
pry finger butthole
butthole
that's all
most of the weapons are viable
yeah I like that too that's good
it's good
I like that
okay didn't I see someone over here
save me please
I don't hear anything
oh are you are you sure
save me
that's sad
this game is sad
kind of like a duh no [ __ ]
okay I gotta take a different path I
guess
oh I gotta go over there I see
one of your favorite games all time
I'm loving it dude
this was like my favorite game all time
and I didn't realize I didn't play the
DLC
so if that says anything
the DLC has only been like better
[Music]
I guess it will depend on how Eldon
Rings DLC does
yep I'm a fake fan
I'm fake
I thought that was like a fake door for
a second
yeah I thought I played the DLC and I've
watched a lot of it I don't remember any
of this area obviously I've watched a
lot of the boss fights but I don't think
I've ever done them myself
behind you
looking behind me
ha
itian room floor two
yeah ring city was lit
I don't think anyone dislikes ring City
just kill me
kill me yeah I have like 2 000 hours on
Dark Souls 3.
someone
I'm guilty
but I won't do it again I promise
frightens me
rises from its very depths
um
so this place looks awful
no sakuro does not have DLC
I don't think it will
I have a lamp
I don't think I have a lamp though
see it at least
guys should I kill them in their
suffering okay
yeah I'm gonna kill him
oh why do they die so awkward
man that sucks
foreign
came out and they moved that team right
over the Eldon ring I think so too I
think Elden ring was in development from
like
2017 2016. I think they had it in
development
I think they started right after Dark
Souls 3's ring City came out I would
imagine
it was like 2017 I believe
[Applause]
if I had to guess I'm not entirely sure
okay this area is awkward what am I
getting hit
is like Arkham Asylum
I mean that would make the most sense
right right after ring City
then they had a team work on sakiro
probably to refine the combat
development you know
which I wish had more of a was more
prevalent in uh Elden ring the heroes
combat that would have been cool
[Music]
hey that was a lot of those guys man
competitive oh we got one chilling in
the corner
hello
okay hopefully he wasn't nice because I
just murdered his ass
yeah he's probably some sad guy who
wanted to die
[Music]
all right y'all stay over there I don't
care I'm gonna go this way
I think bloodborne and Sakira are Peak
as well I think Dark Souls 3 was
obviously their Peak too
what are you holding sir
please stop
please put that down that is not how you
use that
thank you sir
I've never even tried Neo
I don't think I want to either
I mean I could give it a shot someday
okay this looks dark scary and awful
I'm not gonna go down there
[ __ ] that
you should
maybe someday
I've heard most people say to try neo2
instead of Neo one
Auntie titties excellent anti-titties
required
hey what's this
patient room floor
room four
can you guys go back to not wanting to
kill me
I'd appreciate that okay
dude that grab move went on for an hour
[ __ ] you mate
uh there we go
like to eat near too much more gotcha
this is what I keep hearing
I know little Aggies said that he
[ __ ] hates Neo
black myth wukon
I have no idea what that is
nope I've never played Dragon's Dogma
that's a turret
That Could Have Ended that run real
quick
we gotta go this way
another man with a [ __ ] Pole
[Music]
[Music]
sir
like I told you upstairs put that down
you are so hard to read
here we go
oh man
you guys are crazy at least they give me
blood vials
the next boss is name defines this chat
oh God
my Nera boss
what does this say
it's a little glare looked like a
message on the ground
pretty sure those things give me like a
ton of wisdom or Insight not wisdom
so this thing
oh
bye
you're always near a boss I guess so
I guess so man
[ __ ] is that thing
okay
just looking around real quick
I like what that bird did I I appreciate
him doing that
I'm good blue-eyed how are you
oh is that brain fluid I can give that
to that chick
hopefully it'll cure her or something it
probably won't
[Music]
Splish Splash I'm Taking a Bath have you
heard how curiously the sea
particularly
but like the rain only gentle like
dripping water
it balance from deep inside of me why'd
she say deep like that
through my inside okay but gently
like little droplets
have you heard how curiously
[Music]
brain fluid
how do we go back to that girl
yeah I hit it one time and it was dead
you play golf I do play golf I played
professional golf for
four years
and then I
uh got hurt
with um I hit the back of a tree root my
right wrist had nerd nerve damage for a
very long time and I did a bunch of
physical therapy
and now I'm playing a lot of golf and
I'd like to play some more
I don't know if I'll ever play
professionally again but
yeah
that would be cool I'm definitely trying
I play a lot like a lot do I need to
jump down I think I do
actually there's a
ladder right over here
let me hit the ladder real quick
pro golfer vibes
boats
such a Vibe bruh
uh I've tried disc golf and I'm ass
I always lose my frisbee
which the same frisbee I'm sure is just
like yeah you don't know what you're
doing
should have like multiple frisbees
[Music]
we're getting some good blood gems that
we need to upgrade as soon as we can
70 and four nice man
that is like one thing that I'm thinking
about getting into
perfect
we're fine no we're not why are you
there
why what are you doing there sir
I was gonna say I would like to get into
like some type of like martial art for
exercise but
we'll see
oh hey
not a Pity sight is it
the true face of the blood worshiping
Beast purging healing Church
but that's not all
you seek this
held by the nightmare do you not
okay trying the astral crocodile
killed Maria oh [ __ ] she hides the real
Secret
that sounds hard
guys
it just sounds difficult
okay
I want to know this the specific drugs
that Hideki used to make these games
please I have brain fluid here
oh it's wonderful
oh
I hear the sticky sound he snorts zebra
sweat
oh
will you have my blood as
that I'll have you know
I was once a blood Saint too
do I accept this is it bad I'm gonna
accept it that makes me happy you're
welcome but I cannot move
look on my right arm
I'm sorry to trouble you oh but you
don't mind do you
blood oh nice
oh there you are don't be greedy
as they say
Fear The Thirst for blood is that how
they say it
I was once a blood Saint too
why does everybody laugh at me
am I funny or something
yeah I hear fear of the old blood
he snorted brain fluid
I I feel like there's something going on
there that we don't know fully about
with miyazaki's potential drug habits
foreign
I think he's just that creative
yeah the hunter that killed me
to have
a brain fluid thing behind it
inflating through
it's okay
[Music]
oh I feel bad for these people I really
do
are people
oh [ __ ] I was not expecting this what
the hell is this
Living Faith failures
it's me
whoa
oops
okay there's more
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
I like the music a lot
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
what are they doing what are they doing
I don't like this
[Applause]
foreign
why am I doing no damage to these guys
look I'm doing nothing
there are just so many meteors okay yeah
that's cool
what up trade I made one joke I said
living failures that's me
I also do have bolt paper is Bolt paper
good against them
who's the failure now I mean me
obviously
pretty pretty clear that it's me
hi Daddy
soft off my level
bye
[ __ ] bye
he doesn't even die
they are weak against a different weapon
and yes use bold paper
I have failed yes you have you are a
literal living failure
thank you
I'm dead
[Music]
[Music]
the headbutts
[Music]
stop it
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
this is weird
[Music]
foreign
there we go
[Applause]
foreign
I think they're coming from One
Direction
we're good we're good we're good
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
right again where okay
[Music]
yes let's go
[Music]
we got it
yes
dude they take so many hits oh my God
okay it always came from the same
direction
One Direction
favorite band
all right guys
okay
yeah that music was sick
for like what seemed like kind of a
random boss
I liked it though
wasn't too hard
we need to go yep nope nope nope nope I
know exactly what that is
I know exactly what that is guys
nope not going in there yet no shot
bucko
they did not give me a lot of blood
Echoes welcome what is it you did
Good Hunter
[Music]
we got one level out of that
one
I'll increase my skill
foreign
doll number two
[Music]
farewell goodheart may you
[Music]
just buy these
[ __ ] it
okay should I fight lady Maria or not
it seemed like it up my physical damage
negation too Brian
[Music]
should we go to her or not
I'm sure there's other areas to go to
yeah all right all right all right let's
do it
okay okay I don't know if you guys are
like yeah you need to come back here
later or something I don't know
I'm assuming it's aluminum Lumen wood
garden
[Music]
he's not difficult oh don't don't do
that
[Laughter]
foreign
a lot of [ __ ] about this I've seen this
fight but I've never done it myself
RP walk
this is really cool
together
good job Rick you got the me six they
are me six
I'm Mr meeseeks look at me
thank you master I appreciate that thank
you
lady Maria
okay she's covered in blood
is she a doll
a corpse
should be left well alone
bro I agree why am I trying to touch her
to be honest that's kind of weird
okay she let me go
oh I know very well
how the secrets beckons so sweetly dude
her sword looks sick
only an honest death will kill
you
you can break it in whoa
[Music]
all right right into it huh
[Music]
okay that's four
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
what is she doing what the [ __ ]
I don't like that
[Music]
okay you're a sniper got it
foreign
she's got Bloodhound step in rivers of
blood dog
are you kidding me she's [ __ ]
overpowered
she got seppuku she got Bloodhound step
she got rivers of blood like what is
this she's a typical Elven ring PVP
hahaha
the music's too loud okay let me turn it
up
I should have turned it down a little
bit because I think it is a little loud
okay
okay
I haven't seen phase three no I haven't
let's get it
okay that was sick
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
did I hit her here
I wouldn't recommend it
[Music]
he holds that about as long as morgot
holds his spear
and the music was about to get cool
she had a laser beam man
all right this is going to be hard this
is going to take a while I can tell
just wait till phase seven
[Music]
get
the first time in our playthrough
[Music]
or like go farm them
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
that's so unlucky okay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
dude stop
this is not going well
[Music]
[Music]
bad
and abruplant
guys this seems really [ __ ] hard
if I remember right it's easy to Parry
her
what the hell up chat
just just Perry your bro
hey man I mean just [ __ ] barrier dude
just barrier man
who's [ __ ] Perry right
yeah you're [ __ ] dumb ass up are you
kidding me
you guys want to take the controller and
do it for me
your back seat
s
[Laughter]
I mean [ __ ]
I forget where to go to get blood vials
like Farm them
try bro you only shot her once the whole
fight Adam does anybody like you at your
middle school let me know because I
doubt it
I've been a dick in chat for like 30
minutes shut the [ __ ] up
are you still insane
hmm
okay
in front of Ludwig's Arena
is that the best place to farm
I'll just go there
dude where has everybody been back seat
and dog okay there's back seating and
then there's being a dick
you give me bad vibes and they give me
funny vibes
I think I've laughed at them and not at
you
okay underground corpse pile
[Music]
dude
the Skelly dude
the creepy dude
this guy
oh
oh in the front
and if I die I die
gimme viles
oh this guy he gives me
he responds and gives me five every time
well
yeah we're fine
it's here 20 miles he turns into Ludwig
imagine
having this health bar I mean
technically bloodborne we get we're
basically Melania
we can get health back by hitting our
opponent which is pretty cool
[Music]
we beat Ludwig on the first try and then
somebody in chat said I can't believe
you used two summons for the bush
I can't believe it bro
use summons for the best
for the best boss fight in the game
it's like dude
that's another guy I told to go shut up
I do have this health bar
I feel like I need to be stronger to
fight lady Maria does anybody else think
that like should we go to the wet nurse
Maybe
I feel like I'm way too weak to fight
her to be honest like we could get more
blood vials and like really try but I
don't know
I feel underpowered for sure
[Music]
yeah we could get good that is true
[Music]
that means it's just right
excellent
what's your blood level
I mean if you just mean level 63 people
were telling me to be level 80 when I
went into the DLC
[Music]
plus nine
what's my Cleaver at boys yeah plus nine
[Music]
let's go to the wet nurse I'm gonna go
to the wet nurse
I think that'll be more fun
than just like us being here and
like hyper trying to beat this boss or
whatever
okay how do I get back I don't remember
I think it was here
where is cainhurst
where do that be though
um somebody in chat told me to do it
first Adam
because it changes like dialogue with
the doll but I have not seen that yet to
be honest
I need an invitation
when does bloodborne come to PC
are you guys ready for this flip this
moment right here
bloodborne will come to PC March 22nd of
2023.
don't ask me how I know that it's gonna
happen too
clip it and ship it
I don't want to kill her she seems like
she's just in distress
how do you know that don't worry about
it
all right you guys really want to know
why I know that
it's my birthday
and
I just feel like it would be cool
it's the baby
yeah sources trust me dog
yeah my dad works for Nintendo
this thing looks creepy man
[Music]
interesting music
this isn't fair
[Music]
stop it
is this thing like a ghost
ow that hurt
so what I was doing there was incorrect
dodging
bomb
[Music]
my grandson is miyazaki's wife's
boyfriend perfect
all right let's try that again because
that did not go well
if you couldn't tell it
went poorly actually
yeah guys why am I getting like
annihilated
also I beat Ludwig and got like 40 000
Echoes which leveled me up like twice
what is that what what what's going on
yeah is fire or bolt paper good against
that guy
I'll use whatever it takes
Blade armor am I am I playing war zone
both okay
foreign
am I dodging the incorrect side I think
so
Dodge left idiot
ah
chill chill chill chill
[Music]
whoa whoa whoa
holy [ __ ]
that scared me
shit's a nightmare bro
foreign
that scared the living [ __ ] out of me
come here
why do I keep going right
[Music]
huh
foreign
there it is
second try
oh
that's right
is something broke
oh okay nightmare slain one third of an
umbilical cord
I love that for me
give me these back 72k
I got more for that than I got from
Ludwig
damn
congrats on ending the baby's life
listen it's not real it's all a dream
right guys I can do anything I want in a
dream
okay so we just cool with that are we
just letting it burn is that what we're
doing good Hunter
you have come
Dawn will soon break
this night and this dream will end
Gammon awaits you at the foot of the
great tree what do you mean the great
tree
dude they say [ __ ] like this and I'm
like there's no way Eldon ring is not
connected to all the other games very
well
Let The Echoes become your strength
let me stand close
I'm still thinking skill right
yeah
farewell Good Hunter
may you find your worth in the waking
world you guys telling me to eat
the umbilical cord I don't think I've
ever done that
root of man's impurity
rides within filth what is this
you can use it
used to gain a blood gem
did I use this too
people keep asking me to play steel
Rising is there like interest in that
game
Gill will increase visceral damage which
will be good for Maria I think so too
yeah I only have one chord and I can use
the pendant okay
Gold Blood gem I I really should see
what kind of gems we got rocking now
because I think we can definitely like
upgrade
one way or another
maybe not
this one's 178.
we want that one
that one was 203 yeah we want 203
pack of 15 percent
uh
yeah this is better and then yeah it's
just gonna be good
you should go to Upper Cathedral
okay let's do it
three or don't eat
got it
how long will it take to complete this
game I'm pretty sure we can beat it
tomorrow
if I can play for another hour and 15
minutes right now
before I gotta go
you guys said upper Cathedral
where do I go for that
was there just like a door that I didn't
go through
I'm from the Midwest Marcus
I think we have the key
of some kind I just haven't
used it
this one is this the upper I don't think
so
um I mean we've gone we beat Ludwig I'd
say we're like
two maybe
we're more than halfway done
yes okay so I've been here
right
okay we'll go up and up and up and up
and up and up that's right we couldn't
progress before
that's right
man all y'all are weak sauce now bro
they're all trash
strong as hell
you mean in bullets what are you
probably more bullets
ah
oh yeah we should go to the um
the old Workshop as well
in that drop down area
I like the way you guys are thinking
right now now that we have enough Health
to do hello [ __ ] you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
[Music]
okay I'm just gonna keep going up
there's another chord
that I love umbilical cords they're so
yummy
can you like
isn't that like the most raw thing you
can think of is eating an umbilical cord
that's raw as hell
oh yeah people do eat placenta don't
they
okay I need to go in there
is it isn't there like a thing where the
the father's like
put the umbilical cord by Chewing It Off
I swear I've heard that somewhere
don't have the key how do I not have the
key
all right where are we going fam I don't
know how to get that key I don't
remember
to yard our goal
oh right right right okay is there a
faster way for me to get back bro
you're right okay let's do it
like an alley
diagonally
yeah yeah yeah laser beam
let's go to the old Workshop first now
that we're already here
which I have to descend for I believe
uh uh okay so how do I get do I have to
just drop down on it
or is there like a very specific path
where is it okay it's right there
okay I can go here
I'm gonna do this
I think I can just jump
I cannot jump
thank you
no my controller battery okay hold on
let me plug it in
I gotta go left
okay
hold
and
we're plugged in baby
why does I say disconnected
yeah charging
first Bridge jump towards the ropes
hanging down
all right
bet
bed
we don't do Eldon here we do lots of
Eldon here
we do the Elden of the Rings
I like Elden ring I'm not gonna lie I'm
pretty lured out on it though I don't
know about you guys
at least when it comes to the main
videos
got you existed my guy
you existed
[Music]
very very hard
well it's not hard for me
I'm the best
he said first bridge and then I shoot
for the ropes
kind of want to get those
am I gonna get [ __ ]
if I don't
if I go for this
I don't see ropes
you mean those right there like that
platform
that thing
I messed up
that little platform right there is what
we're going for okay can I jump to that
yeah I'm already down too far for sure
unless I figure out a glitch
all right we may have lost out on these
runes but I don't really care
the moment you walk into the room you
gotta drop down on the left okay thank
you
what are you gonna play after bloodborne
I want to play Dark Souls 3.
um we should probably finish sakiro
first though
I also have a meme stream idea
or Friday
because we actually have a sponsored
stream on Friday by the way
I have never had a sponsored stream in
my life
which is pretty cool
okay we gotta go down into the left
so
I see the little platform
do I just like kind of walk off
oh I I didn't want to do that
hey there's the door guys
who is sponsoring I can't tell you guys
I gotta surprise you
it's a so it's only an hour-long
sponsored segment of the Stream
there is no NDA I couldn't tell you I
just don't want to
I rolled into the ropes from off the
bridge
ah this feels like speed running again
ligma
I'm sure you guys could guess it if you
took your time
ropes
I don't see ropes
yes my mother is sponsoring it
walk out on Bridge
guys
it's like dragging me off
I said to go like straight left so I'm a
little confused
like here
oh and then roll I see
I see
I
see
if I just walk here will it Bonk me out
let's [ __ ] go boys
I shouldn't even be using those it's
dumb
the source of the dream
Christ
please bring this [ __ ] game out on PC
if it looks this good on P like
PlayStation bro
you a match
yeah I can sell the doll dress can I
yeah we're selling that [ __ ]
or should I wear it for the rest of the
Run
old Hunter boner excellent
another umbilical cord that's big
can I go out in the garden
small hair ornament
who said Give me like what is that
hello
there's a bloodhound stop
kidding me bro
oh there is no Garden
no Garden
give it to doll
there she is
abandoned doll
dude I really wish bro I could [ __ ]
have the creative genius that Hideki has
it's on another [ __ ]
okay do I give it to her or do I sell it
because I'm pretty sure it's worth a lot
of Echoes
now that we're just burning it all down
like [ __ ] it
give small hair or you meant the hair
ornament not her clothes what
what is this
I can't remember
not a thing only I feel
like a yearning something I never felt
before
what's happening to me
you have feelings tell me Hunter
could this be Joy
I think so
I am so sorry that is your first
experience with with happiness
go on
farewell Good Hunter
I made her cry man and I don't even
think she can cry
wait how do I sell stuff
oh probably at the thingy over here
these guys
you you
you're
hey yo where where the [ __ ] my [ __ ] on
where's my clothes at okay they're here
sell all the ones I don't care about
like I'm never gonna wear this cage
yep
yep I can wear any student crap doll
doll clothes doll gloves doll shirt not
gonna wear this I'm not gonna wear that
that
is sell all my stuff
yeah press uh press one if you've never
felt joy in your life
one
what's happiness
couldn't tell you
just kidding life can be cool sometimes
all right
um
does it tell me which ones I am
currently have equipped
doesn't really give me that much I don't
care yeah this is fine
the cool 65k no problem
any poppy boys
no popsicles
can you beat Melania first try
is that happiness or
is endurance good in this game to have
I'm gonna level it [ __ ] it
is beating Melania happiness or is it
just like
it's more like a finally
type thing
relief
the living failures OST was awesome
okay you guys said I need to go here
right
Stan you're a happy boy
like one of these areas
yeah it's honestly just pure relief
gearman versus Melania Melania wins she
has waterfowl stuff it's over
okay I'll keep I'll keep it at that
I'll keep it at that
yo it's bones let's [ __ ] go dude
how are you man
that may just be a resub and he's not
even here but if you are here I
appreciate it thank you for the six
months of being a literal outer God
you're awesome that's the highest tier
membership that we have
thank you dude if you are here sometimes
people resub and they're not even here
but it still comes up in chat
but
if you are good to see you and thank you
hey where am I going Chapel okay
no I have not beat Maria we fought her
twice died very easily and went
somewhere else
we are getting stronger to fight her
laser beam
we're just doing laser beam I see
okay yeah bones is here guys
hi just a a nice cool hundred dollar
Super Chat
and all he has to say
is high can we get a high in the chat
this is singular high from everybody
bones
I don't know why you do [ __ ] man but I
appreciate it dude thank you
hope you're doing well
I
I really appreciate it dude your your
support is like insane I
nothing I can say but thank you man so
thank you
it's [ __ ] nuts
this guy's gifted a bunch of Subs on
Twitch donated a whole bunch you know
you must like the content I guess
thank you man
I really appreciate you hope all is well
okay where am I going specifically
the same thing like a month ago just a
hundred dollar Super Chat goes High
foreign
yo
you stay right there
okay
still trying to think of where I need to
go
I think I know
I'm probably wrong about that but we'll
see
foreign
also did somebody in chat say that they
already got two days off the school
because of the hurricane
I don't know if I want to wave
at the uh at the monster
good
I'm good
you got two days off work because of the
hurricane
did you guys get out of there at least
get out of there at least
let's go the other way man
okay
where the heck does this go now I'm lost
foreign
I see you chilling up there man
go where the key is I don't know where
the key is brother
I think I know where the damn key is
I'm trying to find
who who am I trying to I'm trying to
fight like the version of this guy ah
I thought orphan acos at a friend's
house
I gotta [ __ ] sneeze
no I have not been to kanehurst I don't
think
go up the stairs there'll be a hole in
the fence on the right side facing the
amygdala
this is an item
you just give me a snowy season LOL
just call my sneeze soy
[ __ ] you
wait isn't there a glitch right here
like literally right here
why do I remember this
I'm a genius
it did not work
but I remember when I speed ran that I
used to do that
nice
okay now we'll go down the stairs to the
left
I feel like I didn't even play this game
like all I did was the speedrunning
stuff
oh
can we go to the uh the other one maybe
Hey listen I didn't think I would die
I love just the Casual like burning of
the church behind us
yeah I went here
where was the other one I was at
work is using me as a butt plug today
what did I miss
oh just all the stuff man just all the
things
unseen
I heard there was a bunch of drama in
the Chess World Adam
someone like use a butt plug to cheat or
like that's what the
they're saying
yeah I'll go I'll go back left but let
me grab these real quick
I'll find it donut don't give me
directions as I'm playing
I'll get there
find it I'll find it
top Lester become peace
[Music]
right it was laser beam didn't I already
like get an area over there though like
I'm so confused as like why I'm still
doing this
I guess there was another way to go
foreign
I need you to calm down I'll get there
if I get super lost I'll ask
damn I kind of annihilate everybody here
huh
now
the back seating is heavy today
as if I don't walk in the
perfect Direction
I get yelled at
it is always with good intentions though
I do appreciate it
but we'll get there
that there was a secret hole
don't think it's here I think it is
outside
oh my God
why are they all back
foreign
there's two of them
oh come on the Gunner doesn't hurt him
oh man
yeah I gotta go above the cage
ladies really got it out for me
guys you know how we were just talking
about backseating holy [ __ ]
I'll get there
holy moly
it's always later in the Stream when
people start going [ __ ] nuts
you're not going where
hey he's back
I gotta go above some
I hear the dinghy dings but I don't see
the dingy-dingy girl
where are you
we front seat and scoot over
yeah
hey man
you know what I'd be doing I'd be
yelling at the streamer
at the monitor
to go where I want them to
however I would not type in a chat
huge difference
massive
there we go
upper Cathedral key
now we can just go back
no no you were being crucified for back
seating when I didn't ask not for
helping
get it straight
there was a chest
dog
I didn't see it
sorry
maybe it's because y'all are typing at
me on where to [ __ ] go that I didn't
see and I'm looking at chat instead
you have four heads you know what Chad
everything's your fault and it's never
mine that's pretty much what I'm saying
here
foreign
I'm sure it is annoying
am I level Maybe
do I have a poppy boy
puppy boy
Gammon awaits
very well we could just go in the game
farewell Good Hunter I'm not getting any
uh Rooney boys okay now we can go to the
upper Cathedral Ward
all right guys
you better chest yourself before you
wreck yourself
I can play for another 40 minutes
okay Kane hurts I know nothing about
I think I can beat the game in 40
minutes
make it 45. all right 39 minutes
because I have until two o'clock I
didn't mean to do that
lady Maria's been the hardest so far
you guys want to do an elder ring
passivis run
oh you guys want to know the meme stream
I was thinking of
for Friday for the sponsored stream
a rick run
but it's where every enemy in the game
is Rick
God damn it
and it scales
think that'd be funny
and then we'll try and beat the game as
fast we can
it would be like yeah it'd be Rick blade
of Michelob yeah
are you lost
all right let's get it
nah we'll find Healing items we're fine
the choir
choir huh who the heck are you
I don't know what that thing was but I
did not like it
mmm
I like to RFP walks sometimes
I died
[ __ ] there wasn't a lantern either man
oh this has been so annoying
okay maybe we go get blood vials
like real
can we go get blood balls
yeah I'm sure it was past them I'm sure
it was directly past them
I'm sure
trailer's right [ __ ] there and I died
I'm going to Ludwig's I'm gonna grab
five to make it seven we'll be fine with
that
foreign
bow only level one run no thanks
I know I was kidding I know it was there
I just didn't think I would die
I could have got some with Insight too
but this is fine
balls
yeah aren't bows like the weakest item
in the game
yeah the blood vials are kind of
annoying I honestly through this most of
this playthrough I have not had to do
what I haven't not had to farm that much
I could have used Hunter's Mark you're
right
we're gonna be fine I think we're fine
now I gotta run all the way back
what up one pump trump
what up dude
uh what up bruh
what up brown
what up bro what up bro what up bro
I mean sleep arrows is the cheese for
the god skin Duo right
where am I going
not the right way
wait are you [ __ ] kidding me
[Music]
why am I so
what is up with this area
can I go up please is there a way to go
back up
let me go back up
[ __ ]
all right
how do I use my Hunter's Mark
waking Anew without losing blood echoes
honors Mark sacrifice all and awaken
anew we have 162 [ __ ] it get me out of
here
damn it
I just look at chat I get distracted
100 yeah dude
bones comes in about once a month
does a hundred dollar Super Chat says hi
and then we don't hear from them again
yeah
and I appreciate him very much
I don't think they're in the
in the ward yet death
now
oh
man you guys are great
pretty neat guys
if you're in the chat I appreciate you
that's all
another baby there
please don't come after me
what is this [ __ ]
there it is
this game doesn't have Rick one out of
ten I agree
good point Steph
no I've never played Dead Space
[Music]
I feel like I don't need to murder these
kids
let's buy a device
[Music]
Great Lake
it's awesome I could try it
wouldn't mind it
I've heard good things about it
[Music]
oh
that was pointless hello little baby
stay right there
your little scythe
whoa my guy
oh I needed that I needed that so bad
because I don't understand how to fight
a scythe apparently
foreign
the music here is really creeping me out
man
wire guard
if there's one dude in the entire world
that I would want to pick their brain
[Music]
Something's Gotta be here bro
oh hello
sir
I reach you
come to the door
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
what the [ __ ]
foreign
agreed Adam
lies of he when it drops it's a
bloodborne and steampunk Aesthetics he
plays a Pinocchio
that sounds cool I'll play that
never trust a window
I can't [ __ ] see
[Music]
foreign
holy [ __ ]
it's a nightmare it's a nightmare
foreign
[Music]
what's happening oh God
don't kill me just don't just don't [ __ ]
you
oh my God just let me get out of here
oh Jesus
I missed when there was light
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm over it
ritual blood oh come on
this is actually the scariest area in
the game so far
you should check out a game called Elden
ring
why is it good
[Music]
I need to buy that Lantern don't I
chunky boy we're looking for a stone
a latter
I heard Elder ring sucks yeah me too
Sam
what's going on in this hallway bro
a lot of elixir
I mean that just seems slightly unfair
oh God
he's stealing my insight foreign
[Music]
there's no way he just
[Music]
[Applause]
is this is this not the Demon Souls
thing
is this not Demon Souls isn't there like
sucky dudes that throw a thing at you
and it makes you stop and they run at
you really quickly and then suck your
[ __ ]
like actually is
I don't want to quit out that seems lame
[Music]
okay they all respawn
just let me go just let me go
okay I have to go down this hallway huh
[Music]
it's so [ __ ] fast dude
foreign
wait what the [ __ ]
why am I even here what am I here for
there's a door I didn't see the door
right here
dude no [ __ ] way
I'm murdering you
piece of [ __ ]
oh my God
that was awful
I can shut the door
oh this is where I've been
he stole like 10 Insight where do I go
oh
[Music]
oh my God
dude this area [ __ ] sucks
holy moly
thank you
[Music]
clock
it won't let me out too I like have to
this is such horseshit
yeah it's really hard to dodge
like I promise I'm trying to dodge it's
not easy
this door just opened please thank you
it's
literally gold mask hello
I
I'm doing it I don't care
that's such horseshit [ __ ] my dick
suck my
suck my [ __ ] that is the worst enemy in
this game by far
I'm doing the thing
you guys were right whoever said dude
quit out when it happens you're right
is this not gold mask
make contact
foreign
[Music]
how do I do emotes in this game
far right of the touchpad
oh it's left
uh switch
[Music]
hello
[Music]
uh
did I need to wait longer
I gotta hold it for a minute
[Music]
guys I find it really hard to believe
this isn't a reference to gold mask
[Music]
the more I play this game the more
similarities I see like a lot of
references to Elden ring
or I guess Alden ring uses references to
bloodborne
it doesn't do anything there oh they're
lying to me
are you all trolling
are we trying to troll right now
ah [ __ ]
[ __ ] chat bro [ __ ] chat man
all right all right I see how it is
[Music]
you see how it
no uh-uh
okay orphanage key
where do I use that
werewolf even do that man
bro I hate this area this area sucks
oh it opens this door
it's closed by a device
this area is balls
and do it from the inside
it's just because of the suckers
other than that I like the ambiance
[Music]
oh it's just the door past the
werewolves
gotcha
like it'll open now
this reminds me of little nightmares too
that's a game we should play on stream
little nightmares one and two
we should do that for October I want to
play a bunch of horror games that'd be
awesome
oh I guarantee I do it here
[Music]
it's a good game for October
no it's not October yet we're getting
close
okay do I do it here like this
foreign
[Music]
it looks just like that
it looked like the other area except
it's not glowing
can you not
believe it or not I find you adorable
but you would attack me you [ __ ]
okay I will understand what you guys are
saying
when we get to it for now I don't know
what y'all are saying
the less seal emissary
foreign
whoa we are getting ganked right now
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
what the [ __ ] was that that was a joke
okay
um well
nice
okay then
I will continue on
break window
[ __ ] you
[Music]
you're that boss there's always one boss
that's just like obnoxiously easy
ah
why you gotta do me like that dog
nice
yeah we tried DLC we've been doing DLC
we beat Ludwig and we're trying to beat
lady Maria now
[Music]
guys what the what the [ __ ]
thank you
is this my dear
old Hunter Menace scholar of Damien
[Music]
I have never said I've a hundred percent
of this game ever I said I speed ran
this game
Damian are you [ __ ] kidding me guard
he died to some little [ __ ]
no I any percent speed ran
I didn't have to do any of this optional
[ __ ]
so do I pose in front of her
foreign
ERD
L nerd
smack the booty
the final one
oh God
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
music
page two stage two
[Music]
I'm panicking in her ass
foreign
yes metal I did die
it did
I I think that went quite well
considering
we are gonna Farm runes
not runes vials real quick
um because I think that would have been
we probably would have beat her if we
had more vials
actually I gotta leave in five minutes
okay I'll Farm a little bit and then we
gotta go
I mean this seems like the best way
foreign
are you kidding me
you look like you look like you're
enjoying that my lady
to uh equip that in a better spot
say the least
forgot there was some [ __ ] lady that
just wants to murder me
you know
I hate it here
I hate it here
lady [ __ ] off
thank you
Jesus
yeah I should have let her kill me
you're right that'd be easier
leave where are you going I'm I gotta
take care of joy and then I'm going
golfing
yeah bold I don't lose any but I don't I
don't have that many so I don't care I
have limited number of those you lady
come here
[ __ ] you
yes we will be streaming tomorrow at the
exact same time
I think this is a good time to end
though we should end right here I think
that would be best
chat
thank you for being here
appreciate all the support
L backwards l
I'm out of here I'm gonna go enjoy it
needs some attention because nobody else
is home but me so I'm gonna
I just said I told her I didn't tell my
dog anything because she can't
understand me but I told myself that I'd
be done at two so I could hang out with
her before I go golfing
um so that's what I'm gonna do
we'll be back tomorrow same time maidens
maidens we'll be back tomorrow same time
10 A.M 10 30 somewhere around there and
we I believe we will beat bloodborne
tomorrow
I think we will I think we can actually
beat the game tomorrow pretty easily
other than that oh we switch his sides
look at that now you all are L nerds
look at that
I didn't even do anything you just
switched sides that's kind of cool
um
Friday we're gonna have a meme stream
I'm gonna try and get the Rick thing to
work Joey's literally barking now
because I'm ignoring her
um
and it's a sponsored stream on Friday so
if you all could be there for that I
would really appreciate it
we'll do some stuff it'll be a good time
the the sponsor segment's about an hour
long
so
other than that we're gonna be doing the
the Rick stream I believe so
thank you all for being here appreciate
every single one of you we'll be back
tomorrow
peace and love metal I'll play Apex
tonight if you want to
I'm out of here
bye everybody have a great day bye bye
bye